hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba what is
your name Casey Spivey is here Casey
just informed me that at an upcoming
sketch that she's gonna be doing she
will be playing Captain Marvel's segue
check out Casey's channel blonde jokes
too sketch comedy channel guys there's
some funny sketches on there I'm telling
ya it's worth it one day I'll be in one
of those sketches no we're gonna watch
the day from a looper so I was bringing
it up why Avengers for well blow you
away I'm excited to check this video out
loopers a great Channel people hey real
quick I want to give a patron of the day
shoutout to a man named Derek Mitchell
Derek has been having a rather rough
week lately dude I'm sorry to hear that
but I know you're a big Marvel fan I
know that me saying that is not gonna do
anything to really cheer you up but I
wanted to tell you man every one of us
knows what it's like to have a rough
week Casey and I might be all smiles but
on the inside we are depressed human
beings empty souls we're just here to
try to make you smile today specifically
just you if you're if this video gets
one view and it's from anyone I hope
it's you I hope it's you in the context
of the blockbuster Marvel Cinematic
Universe Avengers infinity war has
posted some of the most I topping box
office numbers in film history yes
clearly Marvel fans around the world
were anxious to see how the studio would
start to wrap up the long saga of the
Avengers Thanos and the Infinity stone
important audiences were left pretty
shaken by the film's ending
yeah they're all dead permanently why
are they shorter cookies in May 20 19
the 4th Avengers movie will be tasked
with tying up a sprawling saga connected
to numerous inter woven films and all
signs are certain pulling it off in
style
the stuff we've already seen two clues
regarding what's to come here's a look
at all the reasons Avengers 4 will blow
you away
a cosmic culmination infinity war took
the saga of the Avengers to new heights
dramatically raising the stakes of the
conflict with daños by having the mad
Titan actually succeed in wiping out
half of all life in the universe but
Avengers 4 will give us something that
the MCU hasn't had to face until now the
conclusion
according to Marvel Studios mastermind
Kevin Feige Avengers 4 will completely
wrap up the decade plus story that
started unfolding with 2008 Iron Man
Feige told Uproxx
characters like spider-man or Batman or
James Bond or Iron Man who have been
around for so long and are always
refreshed in comic books or novels and
movies you don't necessarily get that
kind of an endpoint and we wanted to do
that which is what these next two
Avengers films are uncharted territory
pull these and fans of the MCU know that
the studio has never directly adapted a
story from the comics the rather used
marvel's decades of print storylines for
inspiration the most obvious example of
this is Captain America Civil War which
took its title from a famous story arc
but which shares only a few basic plot
points with its namesake infinity war is
a loose adaptation of the Infinity
Gauntlet limited series but for Avengers
for Marvel isn't dipping into its back
catalogue according to directors Joe and
Anthony Russo it will be a totally
original story Joe Russo explained I
don't think there are any comics that
correlate to it I think we're in pretty
fresh territory with Avengers 4 I have
no interest as a director in telling a
story that's already been told or in
seeing one that's already been told if I
know it a mass of the story is the
going to happen some what's the point of
going to the film that's a good point
and one which means that vans looking to
Marvel comics for clues to the conflicts
outcomes probably aren't going to find
them that's why I'd never read source
material and never keep its secrets
completely under wraps and some leaked
set photos may provide interesting plot
oh yeah
in particular it appears that the
remaining Avengers may be looking for
clues as to how to reverse their
greatest defeat by revisiting their
first victory the Battle of New York via
some kind of time travel set photos have
shown a recreated theme from the famous
battle with the original Avengers
sporting their phase 1 attire and
ant-man along for the ride with the time
stone currently residing in Thanos's
Infinity Gauntlet it's likely that this
will be achieved through purely
scientific means or maybe it's all a
recreation accomplished with Tony
Stark's BA RF technology comes civil war
by nearly augmented retro framing or
barf Joe Russo is hinted that this might
be the case saying certainly there is a
5 minute sequence in civil war around a
piece of technology that was laid in for
a very specific you may get a hint as to
a direct this may be misdirection
returning cast in case you doubt that
the Russos would use devious tactics to
keep us guessing remember that they've
gone out of their way to suggest the
deaths depicted in infinity war may be
permanent but if set photos and comments
made by the MCU stars are any indication
this is almost certainly a big fat lie
you get hurt put them back get killed
walk it off speaking to the independence
Bucky Barnes actor Sebastian Stan
described a scene in which he said quote
everyone was there including Hank Pym
and Janet Van Dyne neither of which
appeared in infinity war Henry Eyring
who turned to dust and infinity wars
post-credits sequence likewise
zoe saldana let slip the e-news that the
cast of infinity war was only getting a
short break between films because i know
that we will have to all
come back at some point this fall and
finish up the second the fourth
installment of Avengers the biggest hole
in the Russos threat during an event
with the lighter small but mighty is one
of two sandwiched between infinity war
and Avengers 4 had fans speculating
early on that Scott Lang could play a
key role and Panos his eventual defeat
the set photos featuring Lang alongside
the Avengers at the Battle of New York
seemed to bear this out along with Joe
Russo's comments confirming a fan theory
regarding the soulstone @qa
Russo implied and later debunked that
the soul stone colored world in which
Stannis visits a young Gamora was
actually the stone itself we may not
know yet exactly what was going on with
what they called a spiritual
representation of Kimora but the
question remains are those wiped out by
the mad Titan trapped inside the stone
in comic book that may be or ant-man
comes in we all know that ant man's
ability can get him into some very tiny
spaces especially when he screws with
the regulator on his suit
we had to shoot between the molecules to
get in there his ability to navigate the
quantum realm might also help provide
the scientific basis for the Avengers to
achieve true time travel one way or
another it seems all but certain that
the tiniest Avenger will play a crucial
role in our heroes ultimate victory and
its power
mocking the epicness rockets liftoff
ant-man leading the charge in Avengers
four would be in perfect keeping with
Marvel's habit of giving rich emotional
story arcs the characters that may have
once been seen as mere comic relief for
a perfect example look no further than
Rocket you've gotta be kidding me
much like Ant Man Rocket was introduced
as a petty criminal hiding a part of
gold who's forced to learn tough lessons
about trust friendship and sacrifice
leaving him is the only Guardian
standing at the conclusion of infinity
war was certainly not a random choice
Anna would be just like Marvel to write
a pivotal arc around a fan favorite
character who never should have worked
in the first place I'm sorry I can only
afford to lose one friend today back on
target the amount of flack the Russo
brothers taught for its saluting Hawkeye
from infinity war was somewhat
surprising considering how malign the
character has been by fans didn't see
the carrot in an interview leading up to
infinity Wars at least we did not forget
Jeremy Renner we cooked up a story for
him that is a little bit of a long play
not a short play Renner himself has
teased the avenging archers triumphant
return in Avengers 4 but he didn't have
any juicy spoilers to offer up he said
everybody's got to bite their tongue but
if you like infinity war there's some
stuff to come what I do know is it's
going to be awesome you know not spoiled
either in stomaches view with 24 teams
Captain America the Winter Soldier in
which we learned that caps best friend
Bucky Barnes had narrowly escaped what
seemed like certain doom and Captain
America the First Avenger and instead
been molded by Hydra into the
brainwashed cyborg assassin Winter
Soldier
cute house but we're arrested his MCU
appearances Bucky is undergone a painful
character are struggling to break free
of his programming and regain his
identity in a recent interview with
London radio stations spin 103 eight the
Russos revealed that understanding
Bucky's art is the key to understanding
their entire approach to the MCU they
explained that Avengers 4 would complete
the journey they began all the way back
in the second Captain America movement
so the story that began in Winter
Soldier and that ends in infinity
adventures adventures 4 is there's a
very personal arc there for us
Titan matchup ok the opening moments of
Avengers infinity war made it clear that
Thanos is by far the most formidable
opponent the adventures of pace however
if Kevin Feige is to be believed panis
isn't the most powerful character in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that would be
captain on a collision course with the
mad Titan in Avengers 4 Feige left no no
tells a man with vulture
her powers are off the charts and she's
introduced she will be by far the
strongest character we've ever had
screenwriter Christopher Markus who is
co-written all of the Russos MCU entries
tease that the captain is even more than
the sum of her abilities saying she's in
some ways the closest to Captain America
a person who's right and knows their
rights and doesn't really want to hear
it when you tell them they're wrong
marvel cinematic multiverse Sochi stars
who when asked about all the shocking
results of panasas infinity stone
powered finger Sam but at least one
response to the question of how all
those characters might return has
prompted some intense speculation from
fans speaking to The Huffington Post
Anthony Russo said people become
accustomed to time moving linearly in
the MCU that doesn't necessarily have to
be the case there's a lot of very
inventive ways of where the story can go
from here
of course Marvel fans know that the
comics don't take place in just one
universe but dozens or even hundreds of
them known as the Marvel multiverse
Russo's comment may hint at the fact
that we could see the same device
employed in the MCU seizure beyond
Avenger
for a development dr. strange star
Benedict Cumberbatch seems to think his
real possibility he told cinema blend
what we've seen happen within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is this
ever-expanding Couture of superheroes
and I think now we're at the stage where
this universe even within our world has
gotten quite crowded and it's just about
to explode into other dimensions of
course this may all be more misdirection
or we may be about to witness the birth
of the marvel cinematic multiverse on a
good line that was well done marvel
cinematic multiverse a multiverse
can you imagine man whoever did this
video it's a very good job John Humphrey
great job buddy I was very
well-researched I felt like I got in
some insights and stuff oh man here we
go let's talk about some of these
Captain Marvel I don't really know a
whole bunch about I really feel like
they're setting her up to be the next
head of the Avengers and which i think
is a smart move it seems like it could
be a natural move - it's like sometimes
things can be a little manipulative
maybe even there's manipulate it might
be good right in the hole like taking
you know advantage of the whole feminist
empowering stuff sometimes that can feel
like it's shove in your face but I think
Captain Marvel from what I do know about
her and I know I made a comment earlier
about I don't resource material I
actually do sometimes I read the whole
Infinity Gauntlet comic book I'll have
you know yeah
20% off antic nerd I do think that would
be a really a really cool thing
especially because she seems stronger
than cap but she also has the same
similar values to Captain America I'd be
pretty excited to see her be the next
head of the Avengers in leading the
charge but where has she been this whole
time which is what the Captain Marvel
movie will explain because it sat in the
no IDs no IDs good times 90s kid right
yeah born in 1975 you're 40 years old
look at ya I'm a nice boy ninety-two
you're 92 yeah I shouldn't reveal your
age or an actress
I don't care they can know yeah but once
you hit 30 you're like 68 getting older
is a reward like you know what I mean so
you should be proud days I'm kidding the
older you get the harder you get people
embrace it I think so it's like wisdom
and wise you know yes Potter on the
inside the older you give you I'm just
messing with you Casey
I'm trying to be positive about what's
happening to me I've been diagnosed with
age I'm trying to just be optimistic and
find the silver lining trying to fall
under the under the mist of the beauty
industry
tell them you have to spend gazillions
of dollars keep keep looking young how
about I just look old I just do that
yeah radio is always a good option well
you're like me I like getting both your
reactive videos are gonna be hard yeah
out of nowhere what keeps dad I'm still
trying to make this platform work yeah
can't wait I don't believe it D aging
technology I believe it just D aging
yourself by he says you don't
necessarily get that kind of an endpoint
he's talking about like all these other
kind of films he's basically saying the
next two Avengers films there'll be like
kind of a actual solid conclusion and
I'm wondering how much of that is to be
taken as literal as they're setting it
up to be like you don't think they're
gonna try to do it's like where does
that mean 84.5 yeah like were they going
with that exactly as I mean all the
characters are not gonna have their solo
films continue like the ones that were
introduced from phase one like Captain
America I mean everyone's kind of
expecting cat to die especially because
Chris Evans is like yeah I'm definitely
believing after Avengers 4 or as Iron
Man gonna not have his solo films
anymore but then I'm thinking about
wealth or just got rebooted and everyone
loves the reboot of 4 where does this
really go I did hear some stuff about
how Mark Ruffalo was talking about how
they wanted from Thor Ragnarok to
Avengers 4 to be an arc for the Hulk so
I could see what they're talking about
there but the way people have been
talking about what he's saying here kind
of makes it sound like they're really
concluding it but I'm like Mather
they're gonna be continuing in there
it's not just an endpoint yeah I mean
there's TV shows and stuff that are
happening - I think they might do it
like actually and some people they feel
like Captain America they're probably
gonna conclude especially because of the
Russo brothers biggest heart seems to be
with started from Winter Soldier where
they got brought on board and right I
have a very big personal spot for cap I
think you know just realistically the
actors you gotta release the actors you
know yeah they're gonna move on I think
this is I think they want to end on a
good note let everyone go move on to
other projects and maybe do this
multiverse thing that they were talking
yeah I think that they could recast yeah
I mean he talked about that one point
five year terms of like how they recast
bond all the time this should be open to
recast it's like every cast and
supporting players before to recast a
lead would be a big deal
I mean there
casted Edward Norton to mark ruffalo but
Edward Norton's home wasn't that big I
think they could definitely do it and I
think that you and as your chance to be
up for whatever character you want Black
Panther doing it guys I'm gonna be Black
Panther I'm gonna talk to us like me
from California yeah Black Panthers
California sarcastic whole new approach
I mean the original Avengers were the
ones who were left standing plus you
know rocket raccoon raccoon I guess if
it happened I wouldn't be all surprised
they might conclude their specific tales
but I don't think it means like their
films are necessarily ending their solo
outings I feel like they're gonna be
setting up for other ones we know
spider-man twos coming out but he was
one of the people who faded I've seen
the set photos where they have that are
obviously revisiting the Battle of New
York from the first Avengers movie I
thought what was happening was a
time-travel sequence to see Mikey it was
just setup for that for them to go back
to the beginning and try to figure it
out but they introduced in civil war
with the barf technology whatever
the acronym is for by nearly augmented
retro framing or barf the Russo brothers
for them to quote saying that there's a
five-minute sequence in there that's a
that could be like a hint for what might
be happening I'm like oh wait a minute
that actually could make sense for them
to just be using the technology to go
into the memory and everything to try to
figure something out because I was
thinking like there's a quantum realm
will that lead them to figuring out
time-travel stuff that's an exciting
idea to me I'm not sitting here now
convinced that all they're gonna do is
time-travel like it could be this option
I there's an outhouse but before I was
just thinking oh they're definitely a
time-travel right but this one I would
be more curious to see if they try to
solve something by using this technology
because this technology is yeah because
it's barely talked about in civil war so
if that was like a clever setup for
Avengers 4 I'd appreciate that a lot
more ah that was a good catch by these
guys yeah I mean I like that the last
movie was about something kind of
existential
yeah it's about something a little bit
more than just like a physical like yeah
I have to stop and from killing
everybody it was like I really you know
to contemplate like morality it was like
a bigger issue yeah and I wonder if
they'll wrap it up in the same way or if
it'll be like no we just got stopped
this guy in there I feel like it'll get
bigger I mean it's kind of crazy how
much is leaking for this movie I mean
hey these cast members don't seem to be
all that smart I was surprised that Zoe
Saldana would actually say it's like we
all we all know that like majority of
you were coming back we know that at the
same time I'm like but don't don't say
it you know like really got spider-man
to set photos they're working on bunch
of stuff it's been greenlit already you
know they're playing it close to the
chest on this one close to the vest or
do you think that they're telling them
to to tease it so that we'll talk about
it yeah I mean that could be the other
thing too I mean Dave Bautista this
videos a couple weeks old Dave Bautista
has gone through a couple of changes
with Disney since this video was made
you know with him like practically
threatening to try to leave Guardians
with the whole James gunfire but he was
even saying here like like we it's
already confirmed he's gonna be in
guardians three Avengers four but Zoe
Saldana specifically is is the big one
I'm like okay bring him back to Axius
from the snap all right everyone from
the snap who's talking about a sequel I
don't really care about but Gamora
specifically you were the one who seemed
to have the most finite death right you
know like for you to talk about coming
back yeah II know II
it's like Loki dies but you're also like
yeah you know Loki dies a lot I
mentioned my comeback so or whatever did
some other characters envision I'm like
yeah you might be able to build him back
Kimora was there like the emotional
devastating right so for her to just
talk candidly about yeah we're gonna
Avengers for at least let it settle and
those be surprised when you're back yeah
I find it funny with the whole Hawkeye
thing because Hawkeye tends to get a lot
of crap when he's not around
everyone's like
[Music]
never please never complete the fans it
seems like the Russos have something
special in mind for him so it's nice the
whole the upset of where's Hawkeye you
better be something amazing and it
Avengers for honestly guys you can
that's yours right yeah thanks for
coming hey guys you can um no wait no
you she asked a youtube question what's
a good YouTube question what do you mean
a youtube question you know like what
what what are your theories for Avengers
4 hey there you go hey guys what are
your theories for Avengers 4 alright you
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell and please check
out Casey Spivey on her YouTube channel
links everywhere around this video and
check us on patreon full-length TV show
reactions Weckl a Q&A is and music video
coverage would love to have you become a
patron oject
today yeah catch Thanks I played bball